♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
GEORGE BUSH SPENT THE FIRST
NINE YEARS OF HIS RETIREMENT
IT'S A DIGNIFIED AND
RESTRAINED POSTURE THAT IS
LONG STANDING TRADITION
AMONG FORMER CHIEF
EXECUTIVES.
BUT NOBODY IS STAYING SILENT
IN 2018 SO PRESIDENT BUSH IS
NOW SPEAKING OUT AND HE HAS
A CAUSE.
SEEKING AMNESTY FOR MILLIONS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
HIS ADMINISTRATION ALLOWED
IN TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE CONTEXT FOR HIS LATEST
REMARKS WAS A SPEECH THAT
BUSH WAS GIVING IN THE
UNITED ARAB EMIRATES.
THAT'S AUTHORITARIAN
ISLAMIC.
ALONGSIDE HIM CONVICTED
FELON AND FINANCIER.
DURING HIS REMARKS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID HE
WANTS IMMEDIATE AMNESTY FOR
DACA RECIPIENTS.
AMERICA IS THEIR HOME HE
SAID.
CONGRESS HAS GOT TO GET IT
FIXED.
BUSH EXPLAINED THAT WE MUST
EMPLOYEE WAGE FEEL LIKE
PAYING AMERICAN WAGES.
THERE ARE JOBS AMERICANS
WON'T DO THE FORMER
AND WELCOME THEM.
WELL, THIS IS THE MAGICAL
WORLD OF OUR ELITES.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER HAD TO
WORRY ABOUT HOW ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS MIGHT EFFECT
THEIR KIDS' SCHOOLS OR THE
CRIME RATE IN THEIR GATED
NEIGHBORHOODS OR SOCIAL
COHESION OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
INSULATED FROM ALL OF THAT
INSTEAD THEY REPEAT
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH
THREE TIMES LIKE A SPELL AND
PRESIDENT NOTED CAN SHUT UP
AND SAY THANK YOU.
POLICY WORKING OUT SO FAR?
WELL, LET'S SEE.
WE WATCHED DREAMERS BLOCKADE
DISNEYLAND.
WE WATCHED THEM HARASS
LAWMAKERS OUTSIDE THEIR
HOMES TO DEMAND AMNESTY THAT
THEY HAVE NO LEGAL RIGHT TO.
THAT'S OMINOUS ENOUGH THERE
ARE OTHER SIGNS.
HERE IS ONE.
LINDA SARSOUR A PROFESSIONAL
ACTIVIST THE CHILD OF
PALESTINIAN IMMIGRANTS.
OPPORTUNITIES THIS COUNTRY
HAS GIVEN HER FAMILY,
BUT, NO.
LINDA SARSOUR IS NOT
GRATEFUL.
THEE HATES OUR COUNTRY AND
THE PEOPLE WHO FOUNDED IT
SARSOUR DENOUNCED AMERICA
AND WENT ON TO ATTACK SENATE
MINORITY LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER FOR THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN.
WATCH THIS.
>> I'M TALKING TO CHUCK
SCHUMER, WHO IS ALSO FROM
BROOKLYN:  I'M TIRED OF
WHITE MEN ON THE BACK PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND COMMUNITIES
LIKE OURS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
FOUNDED ON THE EXTERMINATION
OF INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE A FAT KID IN THE
HIGHEST OFFICE OF THIS LAND
WHO IS RUNNING -- WHICH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A ROGUE AGENCY.
BUT NOW THEY ARE ACTING LIKE
THE GESTAPO GOING AND
PICKING UP PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> Tucker: NOTICE THE CHEERS
FROM THE CROWD.
ALLOT OF PEOPLE AGREE WITH
LINDA SARSOUR AND THAT
SHOULD MAKE YOU NERVOUS.
WE HAVE INVITED MILLIONS AND
AMERICA RIGHT NOW THAN AT
ANY TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
EVER BEFORE?
IS IT STRONGER?
PLEASE.
IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE.
AND EVERYONE KNOWS IT MAYBE
THAT'S BECAUSE OUR ELITES
WELCOME THE IMMIGRANTS BY
TELLING THEM HOW HORRIBLE
AMERICA IS.
AND HOW BIGOTED ITS NATIVE
OUR IMMIGRANTS BELIEVE THAT
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT.
IT'S OURS.
WE ARE CREATING A LOT OF
LYNN IS A
LINN IS A
LIND IS A
LINDAIS A
LINDA S A
LINDA SARSOURS.
THEY NEED A REASON TO STICK
TOGETHER.
THEY DON'T DO IT
ORGANICALLY.
WHAT REASON IS.
A SHARED CULL TURKS A SET OF
CORE BELIEFS?
PICK ONE.
OUR RULING CLASS REJECTS ALL
OF THOSE.
JUST SHUT UP AND SAY THANK
YOU.
THAT'S THEIR ANSWER.
IT WON'T END WELL.
I
SANCHEZ ISA DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSI
SANCHEZ ISA DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSN
SEVENTH DISTRICT THERE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. SANCHEZ, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US
TO PRACTICE DEMOCRACY AND
ALLOWING THE OTHER SIDE OF
>> Tucker: AMEN.
WE DO IT EVERY NIGHT AND I
BELIEVE IN THAT WITH TITLE
SINCERITY.
>> THE AMERICAN DREAM, THANK
YOU.
>> Tucker: MAYBE WE'LL AGREE
ON THIS.
TELL ME YOUR RESPONSE WHEN
YOU HEAR A CHILD OF
IMMIGRANTS SAY TO A ROOM
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON THE
EXTERMINATION OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES?
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE WE ARE A
COUNTRY OF IMMIGRANTS,
RIGHT?
EVERYONE FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD CAME HERE AND ARE
STILL COMING HERE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> WE DID IN A SENSE FORCE
OURSELVES IN TO CREATE NOW
THE GREATEST COUNTRY THAT
I'M NOT AN IMMIGRANT.
YOU ARE PROBABLY NOT AN
IMMIGRANT EITHER.
>> I AM.
>> Tucker: OH, YOU ARE?
GREAT.
I THINK A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS
ARE GOOD PEOPLE, ACTUALLY.
I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THEY BECOME
PART OF THIS COUNTRY AND IN
ORDER TO DO THAT YOU HAVE TO
LOVE THE COUNTRY.
DOES IT BOTHER YOU WHEN
SOMEONE THAT IMMIGRANTS
LISTEN TO LIKE LINDA SARSOUR
SAYS THIS IS A BAD COUNTRY
RACIST.
THIS COUNTRY IS BUILT ON
MURDERING PEOPLE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> I THINK THEY ARE JUST A
LITTLE BIT FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THE LACK OF REPRESENTATION
MUCH IN CONGRESS OR
LEGISLATORS.
MY FRIEND, I AM BASICALLY A
DREAMER WITH PAPERS.
COUNTRY AT 6 YEARS OLD
THROUGH ABSOLUTELY NO FAULT
OF OF MY OWN.
MY MOTHER WAS ACTUALLY A
PROSECUTING ATTORNEY AND MY
MY MOM'S HOUSE WAS BLOWN UP.
AND SO A LETTER CAME TO MY
MOTHER'S OFFICE SAYING NEXT
TIME YOU PUT YOUR KIDS ON
THE SCHOOL BUS, THEY'RE NOT
COMING BACK.
ALL OVER.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> Tucker: I WILL STOP YOU
THERE.
AND I'M IN FAVOR OF THAT
STORY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO GET --
THE DETAILS MATTER TO ME.
I'M AN AMERICAN CITIZEN.
I SUPPOSE LIKE YOU.
DO YOU THINK YOU SAY THEY
AREN'T CITIZENS DESERVE
REPRESENTATION IN CONGRESS?
>> I THINK THEY ARE HUMANS
AND EVERYBODY RESERVES THE
RESPECT AND RESPECT AND
DIGNITY MOST DEFINITELY.
>> Tucker: THAT WASN'T MY
QUESTION.
HUMAN.
DO PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
AMERICAN CITIZENS DESERVE TO
BE REPRESENTED IN THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED
STATES?
YOU SUGGESTED THEY WERE.
>> THEY HAVE A VOICE.
THEY DESERVE A VOICE.
I THINK.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD THEY
DESERVE A VOICE IN THE
HE IS NOT HERE.
OKAY.
HOLD ON.
I'M JUST ASKING YOU, SO
IN THE CONGRESS.
DOES THAT INCLUDE PEOPLE
DOES THE WORLD DESERVE A
VOICE IN CONGRESS?
OUR UNDERSTANDING WAS -- THE
AMERICAN UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT'S WHAT OUR DEMOCRACY
IS.
DEFINITELY CONTRIBUTING TO
OUR SOCIETY AND LIVE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS, DEFINITELY DO
DESERVE A VOICE.
AND YOU KNOW, IF WE WILL GO.
>> Tucker: SO CITIZENSHIP
REPRESENTED BY CONGRESS?
>> OF COURSE YOU DO.
THERE IS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN LIVING HERE LONGER
TIMES THAN I HAVE, AND PAY
TAXES AND TAKE THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL AND CONTRIBUTE TO
THEM.
IT'S JUST IF YOU ARE GOING
TO HAVE A COUNTRY YOU HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT MEANS
TO KEEP IT.
>> NUMBER ONE COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
THIS COUNTRY PROVIDED US
OPPORTUNITY.
HOW BEAUTIFUL IS THAT?
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS COUNTRY WILL PROGRESS.
JAPAN.
ALL.
>> Tucker: WAIT, SLOW DOWN.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU
OF IT.
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO ASK YOU
THESE TWO QUESTIONS.
BEFORE WE AS AMERICANS LIT
PEOPLE BECOME CITIZENS AND
VOTE IN OUR ELECTIONS AND
GET REPRESENTED IN THAT
CONGRESS, SHOULD WE ASK THEM
TO AGREE WITH WHAT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND SPEAK
ENGLISH?
>> YEAH.
THE THING IS THAT THE LAST
IMMIGRATION POLICY WE HAD IS
OLDER THAN THE INTERNET OR
COMPUTERS.
IT'S VERY OUTDATED.
IF YOU WANT TO LEGALLY
IMMIGRATE FROM MEXICO OR
FROM INDIA.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY.
WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME.
I'M GOING TO PRESS YOU,
IVAN, I WANT TO PRESS TO YOU
ANSWER MY QUESTION SHOULD WE
ASK IMMIGRANTS BEFORE THEY
BECOME CITIZENS SPEAK
ENGLISH WELL AND AGREE WITH
THE CONSTITUTION?
>> I AGREE THAT THEY NEED TO
LEARN THE LANGUAGE LIKE I
HAVE.
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: YES.
MOTHER, RIGHT?
SHE CAME HERE TO THE UNITED
STATES YOU WILL OF A SUDDEN.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE CANNOT
WAIT 25 YEARS TO IMMIGRATE.
SO THEIR.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T WANT
TO WAIT IT 5 YEARS.
IT'S NOT UP TO THEM.
FAMILY'S LIFE IS IN DANGER,
WOULD YOU WAIT.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE'S LIVES
ARE IN DANGER AROUND THE
WORLD AND I FEEL SORRY FOR
THEM BUT WHY DOES THAT MEAN
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO LIVE IN
MY COUNTRY?
>> WELL, THIS IS THE COUNTRY
WAS FOUNDED ON IMMIGRATION.
AND.
>> Tucker: NO, IT WASN'T,
ACTUALLY.
IT WASN'T.
IT WASN'T THE FOUNDED AS A
HAVEN FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
SO BUT I'M JUST SAYING WHERE
DID THEY GET THAT RIGHT?
WHY DID THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
MOVE HERE IF THEIR LIVES ARE
IN DANGER?
>> WELL, WE ARE THE MOST
CARRYING WORLD -- NATION IN
THE WORLD, RIGHT?
WE HAVE ASYLUM AND THAT'S
WHAT THE WAY THAT I CAME.
AND THIS IS NOT ABOUT EVEN
EVEN -- DEPORTING THESE
PEOPLE WOULD HURT OUR
ECONOMY SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> Tucker: OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
>> DREAMERS WE WOULD SPEND
ABOUT $60 BILLION.
>> Tucker: LOOK, THAT'S A
WHOLE ANOTHER DEBATE AND I